previously on TV now will you please ud
song plays over slow motion imagery
related to the show during the opening
credits cliche also 97 seconds of
opening credits listen if you can't do
it in 60 save us all the trouble and
just flash warning pretentious bulked
ahead at the start and be done with it
is this a found-footage show does it
take place in the Cloverfield universe
come to think of it that would explain
so much about Matthew McConaughey's
performance
well you don't pick your parents and you
don't pick your partner I mean that's
not completely true
there actually are laws in place and
actions that can be taken if you're
having issues with the person you've
been partnered up with in any job that
requires that's what y'all want to hear
about right Dora Lange kids in the woods
Criminal Investigation Oh
was just a regular type dude with a big
edge not only is the size of Woody's
woodpecker a completely a relevant piece
of information that comes completely out
of nowhere for a character who so far
seems to be the one that's by the book
it can be a burden and authority in in
in vigilance like fathers burden who
talks like this during an interview
where did he train at but Sylvia Plath
Academy for police I remember Bob Ross
explaining how important it wants to
make sure you get the shading of the
ass-crack just right this police force
is obviously well versed in the always
walk at least ten feet behind the movie
star rule is decent on shoes a frost a
procced like guys in prostitute will see
a victim of a home by a seer I sure hope
you'd have a plan for all that time you
saved on not speaking those two extra
syllables you attach an assumption to a
piece of evidence you start to bend the
narrative to support it for instance
because the first 15 minutes of this
show has been full of pompous tucking
head bloat you might think the rest of
the show will be like that too just like
my mom used to say when you assume you
make an ass out of yourself by adding 10
more preventive since stupid timed
I mention this but you have to come
together yes yes it is
don't conjugate O's in the world it's
all one ghetto man let's get a whisk we
are things that labor under the illusion
of having a self this accretion of
sensory experience and feeling dear God
the show is like pretentiousness had sex
with Miriam Webster and gave birth to a
Tarkovsky movie McConaughey rides around
contemplating weird cars more in this
show than he did in all those Lincoln
commercials gratuitous monahan asses
gratuitous that white men can't huh come
to the new-and-improved you're a strip
mall complete with a functional
coroner's office where else can you bask
in the smell of Auntie Anne's Pretzels
and embalming fluid at the same time
this place is like somebody's memory of
the town and memories fading scrotum
beard oh sorry did we get to the part
where the detective truly up Dora Kelly
Lange 28 you stay busy now well yeah I
got the security firm the show shifts
back to these stupid expositional
interviews without warning and I swear
it took me ten seconds to realize we
weren't still at the debriefing session
in some ways you could say this shows
ability to shirk off the typical crime
tropes of drama and plot mechanics for a
more cerebral conversation and discovery
is a good thing except for the part
where I actually want to be somewhat
interested in what I'm watching yeah we
had her work with a sketch artist and
she told us that looked exactly right
yeah you want to call the APB on that
you go we're out of here sheriff's you
know it is you want a wife with only
half the time pretty sure that's the
script requirement for every HBO show
shot anybody kids children one she
passed and you thought your Thanksgiving
dinner was awkward past half what you
were saying before I owe you - I'm nicer
to talk about yeah I'm with Dallas
shires Club here why on earth would you
want to keep pouring salt on that wound
and then I don't hold grudges I believe
that's it leads to cancer yep it's
tobacco carcinogens asbestos and grudges
but why am I telling about dinner yeah
I'm guessing because HBO ordered eight
episodes but the actual plot of the show
could have been wrapped up in three said
her uncle's Danny Phan no pitcher LSU
yeah I watched him play great Marty
comes clean as being the only person
that actually watches college baseball
uh sorry last thing see even the
characters in the show
or apologetic and bored by how long this
is taking one of them is just staring
out a window but you want to hear the
hero's [ __ ] huh
eventually short no not eventually soon
because we just spent an hour here and
all I've truly detected is that these
two worked a murder case a few years
back and eventually found one lousy clue
at the last second of the pilot my
question is how could it be we already
caught him in not even no one's ever
heard of a copycat there's even a
documentary on it about when that guy
who did the music for When Harry Met
Sally went crazy and went after Tina
Barrett and Jane Craig also Mick Haller
would be great at TV since rust slowed
place his hand by tearing through the
Lone Star's when he could have gone
right to whatever liquid gold is in his
flask right now you know the saying beer
before liquor never sicker liquor before
beer time is a flat circle you start
asking questions okay how's this how do
you make a show with two a-listers at
the top of their game this downright
tedious not a good enough question for
you it's truth you're interested in dr.
Tyree's philosophy classes write down if
you're gonna name my member alright you
got a name it something hyper-masculine
okay something like a spike but you
crawl or your king for January the 3rd
1995 my daughter's birthday I remember
living on the moon you know we used to
look up in the sky and wonder at our
place in the stars now you just look
down and worry about our place and then
dirt will you get the cross or in your
apartment you might not ever just stand
there
looking at it time to nut up or shut up
they'll flip you you what flip you thank
you for real no be right back I'll be
right back
when do we get our money dan you aren't
you a healer and a vessel for the Holy
Spirit when are you coming over and make
my son here again